[Musique]
aller pendant le changement de plateau
les invités du jura s'en vont les
invités du doubs arrive le temps qu'il
s'installe je vous la présente cette
troisième circonscription du doubs la
dernière des douze donc circonscription
de franche comté pour ces débats une
circonscription très intéressante
puisqu'il s'agit d'une succession
toujours ouverte toujours indécise une
succession le député sortant c'est
marcel bonnot du parti des républicains
ne se représente pas il a effectué trois
mandats successifs au premier tour de la
présidentielle cette troisième
circonscription du doubs a placé marine
le pen en tête devant françois fillon et
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon est
en dessous de sa moyenne nationale
suivent nicolas dupont aignan et benoît
hamon dans cet ordre tout le monde est
en place ou presque c'est bon on
retrouve dans la coulisse sébastien
michaud pour l'est républicain il nous
rejoindra dans un instant mais d'avoir
christophe bec de radio france présentée
nous nos cinq nouveaux candidats
frédéric quartier bonjour vous êtes le
maire des républicains 200 c l'épicentre
de cette 3e circonscription vous êtes
notaire à baume-les-dames clerval et
rougemont
vous êtes de ceux nombreux qui se
revendique du renouvellement politique
même si vous avez été candidat lors des
élections départementale sur le canton
de bavans denis sommer bonjour jour vous
êtes le maire de grand charmont vice
président de pays de montbéliard
agglomération en charge de l'économie
conseiller régional délégué à l'économie
ouvrier chez peugeot secrétaire du
syndicat cgt puis professeur d'économie
vous êtes aujourd'hui élu à plein temps
il y a quelques jours vous avez
démissionné du parti socialiste pour
endosser l'étiquette de la république en
marche
si le dit marshall bonjour vous êtes
enseignante en histoire géographie au
lycée germaine tillon ex grand chênois
sur le plan politique que vous êtes
socialiste fraîche date adhérente depuis
trois ans seulement secrétaire de
section ps à montbéliard vous avez été
candidate aux municipales en 2014 et
départementales en 2015 à montbéliard en
suppléante suppléante loup viallet à 26
ans et demi vous habitez montbéliard
vous êtes cadre administratif militants
du front national conseiller de marine
le pen vous avez été assistant
parlementaire de l'eurodéputé front
national dominique
il de l'une des 17 eurodéputés poursuivi
dans la fameuse affaire des assistants
parlementaires
vous avez été candidat aux dernières
départemental à audincourt où vous êtes
inclinés de seulement 500 voix face à
david barbier et enfin christophe et
spoliés au bonjour à 26 ans vous êtes le
benjamin de cette élection cette
troisième circonscription du doubs où
vous coiffer de quelques de quelques
mois seulement votre adversaire nouviale
est fraîchement diplômé vous êtes
intérimaire dans la grande distribution
le temps de passer des concours dans la
fonction publique dites vous installer à
belge depuis un an vous êtes candidat de
la france un seul with de jean-luc
mélenchon et sont également candidats
sur cette troisième circonscription du
doubs bernard lachambre pour europe
ecologie les verts christian driano
lutte ouvrière
karine coma pour lui père et bruno
patois pour alliance écologiste
indépendante
la première question va vers vous ferez
le quartier c'est une campagne
particulière pour vous vous êtes arrivés
un peu tardivement après la défection de
christine bouquin où la droite a
souffert de la sphère fillon dans un jeu
trouble et par un candidat en marche et
tout ça dans une circonscription le
front national est assez élevé à 28 un
peu plus de 28%
on aurait pu rêver meilleur contexte non
j'ai pas s'y être bon ou mauvais
contexte en tout cas moi j'ai envie de
faire les choses pour nos habitants pour
notre circonscription pour la france
donc je ferai le maximum avec un projet
clair écrit chiffré que porte ma famille
politique la droite et le centre
c'est une candidature législatives que
nous voulons riceys depuis longtemps
bien entendu comme tout le monde j'avais
envie de m'investir encore plus dans
cette circonscription donc depuis quatre
cinq ans j prétendait légitimement une
circonscription un peu particulière avec
d'un côté au nord montbéliard là il
centre au sud le doubs centrale vous
avez peut-être un petit déficit de
notoriété à montbéliard comment est ce
qu'on fait c'est un petit peu le
problème on veut du renouveau on veut
des nouveaux candidats
novo des candidats connus donc ce rock
leur nouveau il passe aussi par là que
de ddd et l'udc n'ont pas encore été
présentés aux dents des parts dans des
mandats nationaux puissent se présenter
et puis la notoriété on se fera
lorsqu'on sera élu et qu'on travaillera
sur le terrain denis sommer la
république en marche vous étiez donc
socialiste jusqu'à il ya peu
vous avez sollicité et obtenu
l'investiture du parti présidentiel sur
une circonscription je le précise où
vous n'habitez pas puisque vous êtes
maire d'une commune de la quatrième est
ce que ça signifie que vous ne croyez
pas aux chances de la candidate investie
par le parti socialiste comme c'est pas
le problème
là si vous étiez le problème c'est qu'on
a à nouveau
enfin ce n'est pas un problème c'est
plutôt un avantage on a un nouveau
président de la république qui est en
train d'acquérir d'ailleurs une stature
internationale qui a un projet de
développement et transformation profonde
de notre de notre pays
j'y adhère à ce projet là vous ne
connaissez je suis venu débattre souvent
sur ce plateau vous savez que je suis
profondément réformiste et autant je ne
me retrouvais pas dans le projet de
benoît hamon c'est un secret pour
personne
autant je me retrouve parfaitement dans
le projet d' emmanuel macron et donc
emmanuel macron a besoin d'une majorité
pour conduire les affaires du pays
et c'est à cela que je veux me consacrer
totalement vous êtes réformiste dites
vous mais quel parcours souvient enfin
les peut-être les plus âgés se
souviennent du délégué cgt qui menait la
fronde en seulement à la fin des années
à psa aujourd'hui vous soutenez un
président aux idées libérales et que
économiquement libéral assumé
est-ce que là vous n'avez pas fait un
virage à 180 degrés ou pas du tout vous
savez j'ai été responsable syndical
pendant une quinzaine d'années j'ai vécu
l'action syndicale
mais j'ai vu que aussi la transformation
de notre de notre économie en france en
europe et dans le monde
contrairement à d'autres je me suis pas
enfermée dans mes certitudes
j'ai pris le temps de reprendre des
études je suis devenu professeur
d'économie j'ai enseigné de nombreuses
années au lycée de valdoie et dans les
classes de bts bts connu une année
deuxième année et ça m'a fait découvrir
le monde de manière complètement
différent je pense qu'on est vraiment
allé pas que vous étiez des lignes en dc
c'est un moment de mon 2 c'est un moment
de mon histoire je sais pas quel âge
vous avez mais j'imagine qu'à 20 ans
vous n'étiez pas journaliste vous aviez
certainement étudiants ben voila vous
deviez avoir aussi je pense une image
une vision de la vie de votre
environnement que certainement
différente de celle d'aujourd'hui c'est
normal nous sommes des femmes des hommes
et je crois que notre richesse ou si
c'est de parcourir un chemin
intellectuelle qui vous fait progresser
et au final vous sentir bien dans la vie
et surtout être utile à nos concitoyens
si dennis marshall a va continuer dans
cette même dynamique
quel est votre adversaire numéro un dans
cette campagne on a l'impression que
votre ex camarade denis sommaire
concentre beaucoup de vos critiques
oui puisque nous faisions jusqu'à
quelques temps partie de la même famille
politique et que j'ai moi même distribué
des tracts pour que monsieur thunder
soit élu par exemple sur la dernière
liste des régionales
moi je suis une candidate de la gauche
je suis candidate de l'union de la
gauche d'une gauche rassemblée le parti
communiste m'apporte son soutien le mrc
aussi et moi je europe ecologie les
verts n'ont donc il n'a pas malgré une
campagne présidentielle commune qui n'a
pas
les discussions n'ont pas abouti moi je
veux présenter une candidature d'une
gauche rassemblée qui porte un projet
socialiste alors peut-être dans un sens
ancien du terme socialistes sont
s'enfermer dans des certitudes
un projet qui s'opposera à la politique
d' emmanuel macron un projet qui veut
porter un maximum de députés de gauche à
l'assemblée nationale parce que si
monsieur macron a été élu président de
la république l'enjeu ce sont maintenant
les élections législatives et je pense
qu'il serait mon gré et pour notre
république et pour nos démocraties de
donner les pleins et laisse l'essentiel
des pouvoirs à une majorité en marche
qui d'ailleurs dont d'ailleurs je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elle puisse gouverner
ensemble et donc moi je veux porter une
face aux doubistes original originel je
suis de gauche j'ai alors fait être mon
adhésion parti socialiste était la
récente mes engagements toujours été à
gauche au niveau dans ma manière de
vivre professionnellement de manière
associative et ce sont des engagements
que je portais que je ne change pas par
opportunisme louve y aller vous
représentez le front national alors j'ai
beaucoup aimé le 26 ans et demi je ça va
beaucoup faire et vous êtes appareils
dans le paysage politique régional en
2015 pour les élections départementales
vous étiez qualifié pour le second tour
est ce que c'est votre ambition être
présent au second tour d'abord sur cette
législative
mon ambition c'est d'être élu et de
représenter les gens de cette 3e
circonscription du doubs
donc la question ne se pose pas je pense
que après le premier tour il ya un
second tour et j'imagine que une
majorité d'électeurs me fera confiance
pour les représenter et incarner aussi
un rapport à la règle rapport à la règle
tout simplement à la fois de droit et à
notre règle de vie à nos règles de vie
qui ne sont pas respectés qu'ils sont
menacés dans notre pays dans le pays de
montbéliard et je suis ici pour incarner
cette voie là une voix dit qu'ils de
front national mais aussi la droite je
parle de thèmes de sécurité des
problèmes qui sont liés à l'immigration
et au non respect de la laïcité du droit
des femmes
donc pour toutes ces raisons là je pense
que les électeurs à la fois de
montbéliard comme de mach
l'isle-sur-le-doubs mêmes bavent par
exemple pourront se porter sur ma
candidature
bien montbéliard pour parler de cette
insécurité oui absolument oui madame
si vous avez élu l'est républicain c'est
là qu'elle a joués rations et bien vous
aurez vu que sur les contreforts de
montbéliard pas loin de la chiffogne
trois de nos militantes ont été agressés
au nom d' ici c'est l'algérie camp nou
tractions un petit document où je suis
présent avec ma suppléante qui a fait 38
ans chez peugeot on était bien mieux
traverser ces quartiers et je n'y vois
pas de problème aussi grave dans
sécurité doit toujours ce qu'il ne faut
pas se masquer les choses et voir la
réalité en face promet le résoudre
christophe espolio petites questions sur
la gauche du chacun pour soi bien
évidemment la france insoumise fait fait
cavalier seul dans une grande majorité
des circonscriptions alors que ses
alliés lui ont tendu la main lors de
l'élection présidentielle si dennis
marshall a même le soutien du parti
communiste alors comment justifier ce
cavalier seul puisque à priori l'union
est payante malignon est payante jusqu'à
certaines point g 10 jean luc mélenchon
a choisi la stratégie de la tête dure
dire c'est pas de compromission avec des
particuliers voulant partager le
gouvernemnt jeunes à partager
et ça fait 7 millions de voix on
communiste n'a pas gouverné
lors du dernier mans deux parties que
faire hors de ma part mais mais du coup
il soutient votre voisine de gauche est
ce que c'est pas un désaveu pour vous
souteniez le même candidat à l'élection
présidentielle parts mais le parti
communiste en discutant avec nous pour
ces législatives nous on leur a dit on
se rassemble sur une base commune
l'avenir en commun ça fait 7 millions de
voix vous venez me rejoindre
ou alors il n'y a pas d'union mais c'est
un programme qui a fait 7 millions de
voix qu'ils ont soutenus et après ils
nous disent aux législatives
on défend notre programme non on défend
le même programme qui a fait 7 millions
de voix qui n'a pas changé contrairement
programme de certains je vais maintenant
vous il ya une campagne zéro députés fn
c'est vrai que pour empêcher le front
national d'arrivée d'accéder aux
responsabilités
la meilleure chose c'est quand même
l'union à gauche mais l'union sur quel
programme du parti socialiste a changé
son programme après la défaite de benoît
hamon les républicains ont changé leur
programme après la défaite de françois
fillon
nous on a un programme qui a de même il
n'a pas changé c'est l'avenir en commun
une défendue par jean luc mélenchon
pendant un an
non sélection présidentielle et je
précise que vous avez le petit le petit
livre est comme tous les candidats ou
presque de jean luc mélenchon sur nos 12
débat merci christophe on va tout de
suite accueillir sébastien michaud de
l'est républicain hal et sébastien
installez vous vous avez dix minutes
pour interroger nos invités sur une
thématique précise inhérentes à cette
troisième circonscription du doubs s'est
avoué équilibre du territoire en fait la
troisième circonscription est marquée
par une grande diversité des forts
contrastes entre montbéliard qui la plus
grande ville de la circonscription avec
un taux de chômage de 2 un peu plus de
11% dans une agglomération qui accuse un
taux de chômage de 14 % avec un revenu
médian
globalement de 15000 euros et enfin à
côté on a on à mèche où le taux de
chômage est sous la barre des 8% et où
le revenu médian est globalement deux
fois supérieur à ce qu'il est à
montbéliard alors la question c'est de
savoir ça interroge effectivement sur l'
équilibre du territoire et savoir
comment on concilie concilie pardon d
intérêt assez divergents d'un secteur à
un autre raid la parole
honneur aux femmes assis donnie marshall
pour savoir comment voyez vous cette
divergence
c'est une divergence qui est surtout
marquée par une diversité
moi je pense que cette diversité elle
est à l'image de la france et en tant
que candidat à la candidate à la
députation c'est-à-dire représentants de
la nation moi je ne veux pas m'inscrire
dans une perspective qui oppose les
territoires les territoires ruraux les
territoires urbains agricoles ou
industrielles je pense que du point de
vue du député ces problématiques sont
des problématiques transversales que
nous avons en ville des gens qui
travaillent qui sont des néoruraux que
les secteurs soient complémentaires que
les secteurs sont complémentaires et moi
je veux développer une vision de
transversalité à travers l'aménagement
par l'état d'infrastructures qui
permettent de développer l'ensemble du
territoire les services publics c'est
une question dont on a besoin et dans
les territoires ruraux et dans les
quartiers périphériques pour moi c'est
la même chose monsieur j allais je
rebondis sur les différences il ya aussi
il peut garder différence en terme de
c'est un créneau du front national sur
la sécurité les problématiques du pays
de montbéliard
recentre totalement distincte de ce qui
se passe à mes chouchous charquemont
c'est un avantage et un inconvénient
alors les problématiques du pays de
montbéliard en tout cas de la ville de
montbéliard
je pense intéresse aussi le reste de la
circonscription qui les voient venir
vers eux
mais pour répondre à votre première
question je dirai que ont fait campagne
dans cette diversité qui est allié à la
fois la ruralité à la fois une zone
frontalière avec la suisse
la proximité avec l'allemagne et les
grandes voies de communication avec le
reste de l'europe et aussi finalement 7
septembre de sept ponts de la
circonscription qu'est montbéliard ont
fait compagne s'en flatter les intérêts
particuliers ont fait campagne sans dire
écoutée avec moi vous aurez talent
avantage pour le portefeuille
écoutez moi je fais une campagne en
parlant du bien commun en disant qu' il
ne peut y en avoir qu'un seul et que ce
qu'ils ne respectent pas doivent
respecter les règles et ces règles
doivent être appliquées partout la
sécurité et les problèmes de sécurité
qui se posent à montbéliard les
problèmes d'assimilation qui se posent
dans une grande ville reviennent ensuite
dans des villes qui sont plus petites
mais qui ont tendance à augmenter de
taille donc il n'y a pas seulement les
problèmes de sécurité en tout cas et le
problème vis-à-vis des autres pays les
problèmes vis-à-vis du reste de l'europe
et des travailleurs qui traversent les
frontières et de temps en temps aussi
avec des problématiques liées à la
contrebande comme on peut l'appeler de
produits qui traverse les frontières qui
ne sont pas surveillés donc je pense que
c'est problématique
en fait tu regardes tous les gens qui
sont capables de voter et qui sont en
voie de voter aussi et on vote tout
simplement voilà pas pour son petit
portefeuille je crois qu'on l'a bien
compris à la fois pour la france pour la
nation et aussi pour l'avenir du
territoire dans son ensemble monsieur
quartier oui je pense qu'il faut pas
opposer les territoires et puis les
hommes qui habitent sur ces territoires
soient que cette diversité c'est une
force pour notre territoire
c'est une force si la région du pays de
montbéliard et principalement
industrielle industrieuse ainsi que
certains secteurs la vallée du doubs il
ya une vraie force économique sur le
reste du territoire avec principalement
le
l'agricole l'artisanat les activités de
services donc on doit tout faire en
d'être facilitateur pour cette activité
se développe sur nos territoires et en
aucun cas les opposer mais plutôt les
terrains tous vers le tennis mais je
crois que d'abord je suis d'accord ac
mais avec mes collègues il s'agit pas de
d'opposer du territoire la première le
premier sujet aujourd'hui dans le pays
montbéliard c'est la question de
l'emploi on a eu un succès
extraordinaire avec 3008 il ya beaucoup
d'embauchés devront se faire chez psa a
ri chez des sous traitants
moi ce que je regarde ce qui est de ses
quais quasiment exclusivement que des
embauches en intérim on va arriver dans
on a beaucoup parlé je précise sur la
falaise celle encore parler c'est
évidemment alesi et donc je pense que ça
c'est un vrai sujet va arriver très vite
à la fin d'année avec 50% du personnel
qui sera en intérim en production et
donc kg par accepte seulement de 10 ha
mais en force comment un employeur a
embauché en cdd par intérim peut pas
forcer mais qu'on ait le débat public
sur le sujet y compris avec la direction
de psa
ça me paraît indispensable faut pas
opposer vous savez les les salariés qui
travaillent en suisse reviennent aussi
avec du pouvoir d'achat nourrissent une
économie présidentielle forte aussi sur
le territoire contribue à la création
d'emplois sur notre territoire
en fait nous avons ensemble des
synergies qui se qui se construisent là
où j'ai une une inquiétude willy a
nécessité de faire un certain nombre de
choses c'est sur le maintien des
services publics en milieu rural
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
les maisons de santé mais aussi les
maisons de service on pourra y revenir
selon les courants mais ça c'est des
questions voilà qui sont dans les
secteurs des sciences po liu est juste
sur l'emploi aussi un
précarité et puis il service public le
service public il ya aussi comme dit
monsieur sommer il ya les déserts
médicaux faut pas oublier bon je suis je
suis originaire de mèche pour aller chez
un généraliste doit prendre rendez vous
c'est quand même un problème aujourd'hui
une personne qui peut avoir une grave
maladie va prendre rendez vous chez un
généraliste jeudi un sérieux problème
pour ce territoire
je suis à mèche à 4000 habitants je dire
mais si on prend les petits villages où
les personnages et peuvent pas descendre
leurs propres moyens
prendre rendez vous arrivez à l'heure il
ya aussi un problème de mobilité dresser
le constat monsieur hees polio la
solution sur le roux c'est quoi la
solution c'est par exemple le maître des
médecins font des médecins
fonctionnaires dans certains territoires
ruraux par des médecins fonctionnaires
et médecins fonctionnaires oui c'est
comme ça on densifie fait comme pour les
enseignants vous les obliger à aller
mais en arctique et dans un an dans une
zone défavorisée comment vous faites on
leur demande de donner un service à
l'état parce que c'est sûr sur un temps
donné dans par exemple dans le haut
doubs il ya des déserts médicaux ou les
docteurs ou quand un ophtalmo sans s'en
va mais y'a personne qui revient donc
c'est pas normal d'avoir un en attente
pour aller voir un ophtalmo et je je
passerai les autres docteurs mais il
faut créer un corps de mettre ses
médecins d'état qu'ils puissent remplir
ces zones où il ya où il ya clairement
des problèmes de des problèmes pour
soigner alors christophe va revenir pour
son droit de suite mais moi il ya
quelque chose qui me vous avez tous dit
ou presque pas de concurrence entre les
territoires jeu alors je suis très
étonné parce que tout le monde sait et
vous notamment qui est du pays de
montbéliard qui une énorme concurrence
entre les territoires que vous élus
locaux les uns les autres vous vous
battez pour attirer qu' une entreprise
qui une clinique par exemple voilà donc
c'est pas vrai vous vous enfin il ya une
terrible concurrence entre les
territoires
c'est pas un monde de bisounours
monsieur quartier par exemple on a tous
envie d'avoir mené entendu de l'économie
son territoire ce serait mentir que de
dire le contraire je suis d'accord avec
vous mais je crois qu'il faut qu'on
profite quand montbéliard se développent
les petites communes autour ma commune
moi qu'à 50 km de montbéliard en
profitent aussi
donc on a envie d'avoir des services
monsieur parler des des médecins d'état
je crois qu'on y travaille tous depuis
très longtemps sur l'offre de santé avec
des médecins salariés oui ça existe déjà
c'est existe déjà dans certaines
collectivités
c'est une partie de la c'est une partie
de la réponse à apporter à ces problème
des déserts médicaux
mais c'est surtout de redonner
l'attractivité de nos territoires et je
crois que en rendant nos territoires
plus attractif
on retrouvera des médecins moi je
travaille depuis un an de temps sur dans
ma commune pour retrouver des médecins
je vous garantis qu'on a déjà trouvé
deux médecins qui veulent venir ceux qui
veulent venir s'installer et il n'y a
pas que les maisons de santé et maisons
de santé doit être publique ou privée
faut nous les élus je le répète on doit
être uniquement facilitateur pour donner
envie à nos médecins notamment de
s'installer sur nos territoires
et puis leur apporter tous les services
parce que aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'un médecin un médecin qui part en
retraite ces deux autres médecins qui
doit qui font l'équivalent du travail
donc on doit leur donner de possibilités
que leurs gamins puissent aller à
l'école facilement puisse avoir un
centre périscolaire on puisse avoir des
activités avec tout le monde associatif
qu'on a
voilà c'est une façon de redéfinir nos
territoires merci
merci sébastien on va faire revenir
christophe bec allez christophe vous les
avez écouté attentivement j'imagine que
vous avez des questions des compléments
d'information a demandé aux uns ou aux
autres c'est à vous alors on a parlé de
la maison des services publics en tout
cas la présence des services publics il
ya aussi la question du commerce même si
la question du commerce relève des
communes sans doute mais c'est peut-être
cette question qui est centrale dans
cette circonscription entre une ville
centre où les commerces sont ronds et le
milieu rural où les commerces ont du mal
à rester de nice marque elle et quelle
est votre position vis-à-vis de
l'attractivité de de la présence du
commerce à la fois dans la ville centre
est à la fois en milieu rural quelles
sont les mesures à mettre en place donc
à une mesure globale de la première
c'est la réduction des charges est sûre
à la fois sur les charges patronales et
sur les charges salariales
si on ne le fait pas les petits
commerces qui ont du mal à dégager de la
marge ne peuvent pas son ne peuvent pas
s'en sortir et il y arrive à un moment
où les difficultés sont insurmontables
donc cette question là elle est dans le
programme de d'emmanuel macron puisqu'il
y aura une diminution sensible des
décharges deuxième phase i merci vous
êtes en avance au niveau du temps de
parole on va faire circuler la parole
nous via les rapidement sur la présence
des services publics est ce que vous
avez des propositions à faire
on a tenté aussi de répondre monsieur
sommer a perdu devant alors sur le
commerce c'est bien on réduire les
charges
oui mais pour vendre qu'elle produit
pour vendre qu'elle faisait légumes
messieurs ce maire voulait rejoindre la
majorité présidentielle dans marche de
la république en marche qui veut aussi
faire des traités transatlantique ce
qu'on appelle c'est à l'accord
économique commerciale et globale qui
fait que demain les produits qui seront
vendus à montbéliard mèche l'isle sur le
doubs
eh bien ils seront peut-être vendu par
des français ce seront des produits
canadiens ontarien québécois moi je
pense que celle du circuit court terme
nos territoires
merci je pense que tout simplement un
protectionnisme intelligent est à mettre
en oeuvre
si on veut faire des circuits courts
produire et vendre directement au
consommateur
c'est un moyen aussi mais qui ne suffira
jamais il faut s'opposer à ce traité qui
font en sorte que les produits importés
d'ailleurs et fruits et légumes importés
d'ailleurs coûte
ont toujours beaucoup plus cher que les
fruits et légumes produits sur place
c'est pour ça que je m'opposerai à
l'assemblée nationale à ces nouveaux
accords globaux qui sont mauvais pour
les français christophe espolio vous qui
êtes sur le plateau de maîche où
effectivement la question du commerce se
pose comme partout d'ailleurs qu'elle
est quel est votre proposition même si
effectivement dans votre secteur
meeschart que mon le commerce est
relativement présent quelles
propositions pour effectivement
accompagné cette installation du
commerce en milieu rural il faut penser
à revaloriser le smic parce que les gens
qui n'ont pas d'argent ils vont pas
aller acheter dans les petits commerces
si l'avenir du petit commerçant ne sont
pas salariés petits commerçants ne sont
pas forcément ça n'arrive mais je veux
dire il ya six si on augmente le smic
comme il est proposé de 175 euros nets
le carnet de commandes des petits
commerçants va augmenter donc si les
petits commerçants peuvent vendre plus
si on peut être ils vont sûrement
baisser les prix parce qu'ils auront une
plus grande clientèle
donc il faut s'y rendre ce territoire
attractif par par rapport à ça il a
aussi évoqué tout à l'heure un problème
de mobilité quand les personnes ne
peuvent pas se déplacer parce qu'il ya
aucune ligne de transport en commun
parce qu'il n'y a pas de train pas ce
qu'il y'a rien du tout pour se déplacer
les gens ils préfèrent recommandé aux
préfets recommandé un drive de grandes
surfaces j'y travaille donc je vois bien
je vois ce qui s'y passe donc déjà ils
préfèrent commander aux grandes surfaces
qu'au petit commerçant avec quartiers
sur le commerce quel est votre débat que
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est l'attractivité de nos
territoires pour le pour le vivre et
vous parliez une mèche ou mais j'ai
quand même le commerce de proximité se
développe à nouveau dans les communes
proches de la mine on exactement les
mêmes choses
j'avais accueilli un jour un porteur de
projet qui disait vous savez pas à
vendre votre territoire vous savez pas
vendre dans le doubs parce qu'on connaît
pas l'image du doubs on connaît pas le
bien vivre que vous avez dans votre
nouveau territoire et je crois que le
fait de de redonner de donner la force
de territoire permettra aux gens aux
aux artisans de revenir ou commerçants
de revenir bien entendu les circuits
courts
et puis les petits commerces repartent
aujourd'hui donc je crois que c'est une
dynamique on doit avoir notre rôle d'élu
il doit être toujours toujours g16 m
facilitateur est donné dans nos
politiques qu'on mais localement là une
grande place pour le commerce de
proximité et enfin si le dit marshall
quelle est votre position sur le comment
donner un coup de pouce aux commerçants
millions d un coup de pouce au commerce
la question de la relance économique ne
se fera pas à mon sens avec des mesures
libérales porté par emmanuel macron
d'augmenter la csg la tv 1 va précariser
davantage les petits salaires ce qui
peut porter atteinte à la relance
économique je termine et sur la wii sur
des créations sur la question
industrielle on a parlé tout on a évoqué
tout à l'heure par dont la mise en
concurrence des territoires par rapport
à l'aménagement pour moi est importante
également la question du code du travail
et si on continue à démanteler le code
du travail on mettra d'autant plus les
entreprises et les salariés en
concurrence et on accentuera encore les
disparités territoriales et moi je me
pose à ces types de mesures libérales
qui met en concurrence les hommes et les
territoires
merci si dennis marshall je vais vous
donner à chacune à chacun 45 secondes
pour conclure pour convaincre les
électeurs de cette 3e circonscription du
doubs de voter pour vous la semaine
prochaine on commence avec vous
christophe espolio votre conclusion s'il
vous plaît donc que si les électeurs la
troisième circonscription votent pour
moi ce sera aussi pour revaloriser le
smic de 175 euros nets
revaloriser le minimum vieillesse de 200
euros pour pouvoir donner plus de moyens
aux gens ne se loger plus de moyens de
consommer local et comme on a parlé tout
à l'heure
ce sera ce sera aussi de la
reconstruction des services publics
parce qu'aujourd'hui on ferme des
bureaux de poste
on ferme des lignes de chemin de fer ce
qui est enclavée territoire ce qui ce
qui créé de grosses agglomérations
acquis à côte est qui qui prennent tout
est à côté des déserts médicaux des
lieux des lieux abandonnés
il y aura aussi une agriculture
biologique qui sera qui sera développé
en lien avec un protectionnisme
solidaire merci christophe espolio
jovial et votre conclusion s'il vous
plaît alors je n'ai jamais été élu donc
je suis ici
comme un homme libre en tout cas ma
parole et c'est ma conviction est de
rendre la parole à ceux qui ne l'ont
plus c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai
proposé de créer une nouvelle radio qui
prennent les doléances des habitants la
parole au doute enfin je vais être si je
suis élu avec la confiance des habitants
celui qui fera en sorte que les règles
soient respectées à la fois celles qui
concernent notre mode de vie est aussi
une règle de droit
donc je sillonneraient comme l'est
républicain l'a remarqué la conspuer la
circonscription encore après l'élection
je ne cesserai de le faire pendant cinq
ans pour représenter au plus près les
électeurs merci loubia les six dennis
marshall
autre conclusion ma candidature est
celle de l'union de la gauche qui fera
pour la justice sociale la défense des
services publics à la transition
énergétique
je m'oppose coup je me poserai aux
mesures libérales et attaché aux
attaches et parfois on dire pardon duke
sociale je refuserai le recours aux
ordonnances pour modifier le droit du
travail vous aspirer au renouvellement
de nos pratiques démocratiques à une
semblait davantage représentatifs de la
nation je suis votre candidate cette
circonscription n'est pas pour moi une
proie à prendre ou un mandat de plus a
ajouté à une carrière politique
j'ai serait une députée de gauche fidèle
à mes convictions une députée
constructif qui n'oppose pas
développement économique progrès social
et urgences environnementales
merci sidonie un marshal de nice vers
votre conclusion
très rapidement on a vécu les cinq
années d'un mandat qui a ouvert les
aspects été calamiteux on a la chance
aujourd'hui d'avoir jeune président qui
a besoin d'une majorité pour pour
travailler j'entends parler de
redondance mois en réalité ce que je
vois c'est des négociations solides et
avec d'ailleurs l'assentiment des
organisations patronales les
organisations syndicales pour préparer
préparer l'avenir et préparer les
conditions du développement de l'emploi
dans notre pays
si je suis élu je mettrai en place un
comité technique avec des agriculteurs
des industries les enseignants du genre
de culture
pour m'aider à travailler au quotidien
avec l'ensemble du territoire pour qu'on
puisse échanger compris sur les lois qui
sont qui seront proposés et que j'ai un
retour permanent avec eux le terrain
merci denis sommer à vous monsieur
barbier monsieur quartier monsieur
barbier et elle a tout à l'heure à votre
place et pour ça vous n'êtes pas le
premier wallon
voilà moi j'ai pour seule ambition de
contribuer au redressement de la france
contribue au de redressement de la
france avec un projet clair chiffré
porté par ma famille politique qui est
la droite et le centre je continuerai
d'être un élu de proximité à l'écouté de
tous nos concitoyens nos professionnels
de la politique
je garderai ma liberté liberté de
m'opposer liberté de voter les lois qui
vont dans l'intérêt de la france
merci monsieur quartier je vous précise
avant de conclure cette émission que
sont également candidats sur cette
troisième circonscription
vous voyez les noms apparaître bernard
lachambre christian driano karine
comment à pardon c'est une erreur
effectivement mais oui bien sûr donc
odile joannes christian driano karine
coma et bruno patois bernard lachambre
doit être suppléances et c'est autant
pour moi un grand merci à tous les cinq
en tout cas merci à mes camarades de jeu
du jour christophe sébastien j'ai vu
aussi dans la coulisse tout à l'heure
donc véronique et frédéric merci aussi
aux équipes techniques de france 3 qui
ont réalisé depuis 3 dimanche l'ensemble
de ses 12 débat on espère en tout cas
qu'on vous a donné un peu envie de voter
bonne fin dimanche à tous
[Musique]